♪ A-ga-dou dou dou ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds le café ♪
- Je peux vous dire qu'en 74,
LA toune d'été, c'était
"Agadou" chantée par mon père,
Patrick Zabé.
- ♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds le café ♪
- Et effectivement, c'était en
1974 que la chanson est sortie
au Québec. Les gens, c'est drôle
parce que, parfois, vont
m'écrire pour me dire: "Mais
qu'est-ce que ton père a
consommé à l'époque où il
chantait 'Agadou'." Il faut
comprendre que mon père n'a pas
écrit la chanson; il est
interprète au Québec.
- ♪ A-ga-dou dou dou ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds le café ♪
- Il l'a enregistrée en 73, en
fait, il l'a découverte en 73
lors d'un voyage en Martinique
et il l'a enregistré et c'est
devenu un grand succès qui lui
colle encore à la peau. On pense
à Patrick Zabé, automatiquement
on pense à "Agadou".
- ♪ L'an dernier à Tahiti
une jolie vahiné ♪
♪ Avec son ukulélé ♪
- Mais qui a composé "Agadou"?
- "Agadou", c'est une femme et
un homme qui ont composé les
paroles, Mya Smile et Michel
Delancray. C'est une chanson du
folklore tahitien. Une chanson
qui raconte l'histoire, je ne
sais pas si vous avez déjà
écouté les paroles, c'est très
joyeux quand on regarde la danse
mais c'est l'histoire d'un gars
qui va en prison parce qu'il a
touché au fruit défendu.
(éclat de rire)
- ♪ Tape la pomme
tape la poire ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
- En travaillant sur la
biographie de mon père, j'ai
découvert entre autres combien
environ il y avait de copies
d'"Agadou" qui ont été vendues;
on est autour de 500 000, on n'a
pas les chiffres exacts. Mais ce
que j'ai appris aussi, c'est que
sur l'enregistrement de la
chanson, il y a une petite voix
derrière, donc ce qu'on appelle
un "back vocal" et c'est la voix
de René Angélil. La voix très
perchée, la voix très aiguë que
vous allez entendre lorsque vous
allez réécouter "Agadou", bien
croyez-le ou non, c'est René
Angélil.
- ♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
♪ Tape la pomme
tape la poire ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
- Kim Rusk, c'est quoi
la chorégraphie?
- La chorégraphie est très,
très simple. Alors :
♪ Agadou dou dou ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
♪ Tape la pomme
tape la poire ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
Simple de même.
- ♪ Si tu vas à Tahiti
Prends garde au ukulélé ♪
♪ Dis-toi que ces fruits si bons
sont destinés aux gogos ♪
- Comment il va Patrick Zabé
aujourd'hui?
- Mon père va bien dans les
circonstances. Mon père qui va
avoir 80 au mois de décembre.
Mon père qui a le Parkinson
depuis un bon bout de temps.
Il va bien, je vous dirais,
dans les circonstances.
C'est sûr que c'est une maladie
qui est dégénérative, qui
atteint beaucoup sa qualité de
vie. Mais mon père au niveau
moteur, des fois c'est plus
difficile mais au niveau
cérébral, il est tout là!
Alors..
♪ Agadou dou dou ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
♪ Tape la pomme
tape la poire ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
- ♪ Agadou dou dou ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mouds l'café ♪
♪ Agadou dou dou ♪
♪ Pousse l'ananas
et mou